You buy a truck for $60,000
to start a shipping business.
The truck has a useful life of 3 years.
You then have to buy another truck.
What I've done here is,
I've drawn our actual ...
a series of income statements
for our shipping business.
This is year 1, year 2, year 3, year 4.
This is the revenue that we
make in each of those years.
It's kind of a business
that right from the get go
we start making $100,000 a year.
This is all in thousands.
Let me it write that.
This is 100,000.
It kind of just stays steady there.
We just keep making
$100,000 a year in revenue,
for the first 10 years.
Then, we have to pay a driver.
Let's say the cost of the
labor is $50,000 a year.
Once again, this is in thousands.
What I want to address in this video …
This would be a cost.
When you just subtract out the labor cost,
you have $50,000 left.
Then, your other cost is
going to be the truck itself.
What I want to think
about in this video is
how should we account for
the cost of the truck.
You might just say,
"Hey look, to start off"
"I spent $60,000."
In year 1 we'll actually
go out to the truck store
and buy the truck.
Why don't I just call it
an expense of $60,000?
One reality is, you can just say,
"Hey look, in year 1
my truck cost $60,000."
Then, in year 2 I don't have
to spend any money on a truck,
because I have one.
In year 3 I don't have to do it,
but then in year 4 my first
truck now has to be scrapped,
because I used it so much.
In year 4 I have to buy
another truck for $60,000.
Then, again in year 5, year 6
I don't have to do anything.
Then, in year 7 I have to buy
another truck for $60,000.
8, 9, I don't have to do anything.
Then, in year 10 I have to
buy another truck for $60,000.
If you've counted for the
purchase of your truck
every 3 years this way,
your profit would look like this.
In year 1, 100 - …
This is revenue and these
2 lines are expenses.
100 - 50 - 60, this is -10,000
in profit in that first year.
The second year you make 50,000.
The third year you make $50,000.
Just 100 - 50.
Then, fourth year, again, -10,000.
Then, you make 50,000 and 50,000.
Then, again -10,000.
Then 50,000.
To someone who looked at
this series of income statements,
they'd say, "This is some
type of bizarre business."
"In the first year …"
"Every 3 years you lose a tone of money."
"I don't know why."
"Maybe it's being mismanaged,"
"maybe something strange is happening,"
maybe it's because of bad weather."
"Who knows?"
"Then, you make a ton of money."
"Then, you lose some money."
It seems like some type
of very bizarre business
when you look at it from the operating ...
when you look at it from the profit line.
Just when you just expense
the truck every 3 years.
An operating profit is the
profit from the operation.
Before you think about how you're paying
for the operations, how
you're financing them
or taxes, or any of that type of thing.
This is strange, because this
is a very stable business.
It's very strange for
it's operating profit
to kind of jump around like this.
The way that we kind of reconcile this
is by doing something called
capitalizing the expense of the truck
and then depreciating it
over the course of it's life.
I'll cover that in the next video.